khan has become a local hero people from
across india have come to take photos of
themselves with her and some give her
gifts and money muskan shot to fame
after this video went viral she seen
resisting a group of men demanding she
remove her burqa
i am not scared of anyone except the
almighty i thought of him
he was the one who gave me the strength
and now all this respect
i am very
grateful her experience has highlighted
a controversy over a ban on religious
clothing in the southern state of
karnataka that has led to a national
debate about constitutional freedoms
women started protesting after they were
banned from entering class while wearing
headscarves
this sparked counter protests by hindu
groups they marched wearing saffron
coloured scarves to assert their
identity the colour is considered sacred
by many hindus
but after violent clashes schools and
colleges were closed for three days the
state government has backed the ban in
india
the minority businessmen is going on we
are suppressive hindus are suppressed by
minorities
so this is what they have
the allegations is completely wrong
and false they are acting the clutches
of international elements
protests have spread to other regions
authorities in new delhi have detained
students demonstrating in solidarity
with the women a court in karnataka has
allowed schools to reopen but ask
students not to wear any religious
clothing until a final decision is made
many people are getting anxious in this
muslim-dominated neighborhood in mandia
they say they'll only send their
daughters to schools that allow
headscarves and activists say that the
ban could lead to muslim girls becoming
further marginalized and segregated from
others in schools
some teachers are worried about the
long-term impact on students
now once you have stirred
poison into this
otherwise
learning
area
well it might many people may use it for
different reasons at in different stages
so that could be one of the um you know
most unfortunate thing that might happen
hereafter
muskan says she's grateful for the
support she's received and is confident
the courts will rule in favor of those
objecting the ban
she plans to go to university next year
to fulfill her father's dream of
becoming a lawyer
bhavni mithal al-jazeera karnataka
southern india